yeah do you think it's going to be ugly
where are you from the school of thought
or there's going to be a civil war it's
already starting you heard what Trump
said yesterday loyalty I'm about loyalty
but so okay give us your thoughts I do
think so I think Trump is furious there
have been reports for six seven months
that
DeSantis should have said I would
consider it if Trump doesn't run and
DeSantis did has not said that and
you're supposed to say that that's the
Loyalty test I do so selfishly in two
ways I hope it's an absolute disaster
one I think it'll make it less likely
either of them win if they have a year
during which they're just going crazy at
each other and number two I think it
would be hilarious because
um honestly either one could end up on
top I know that there's this idea among
some of my colleagues that DeSantis is
similar to Trump but smarter better
spoken less Gaff prone all these things
Trump is really good with the nicknames
and the making fun of people and stuff
if DeSantis declares and they're
actually running a national campaign not
Florida but a national campaign I would
not understate the possibility of trump
really doing to DeSantis what he did to
Little Marco you know calling Ted Cruz's
wife ugly this sort of stuff it could
get ugly and it's not clear to Santa's
will get the best of it
yeah I I don't know if I disagree it's
it's a
okay so here's a question for you you're
on the inside uh strategy team for Trump
you're on the inside strategy team for
DeSantis yeah what are you telling that
I know but I know you're gonna say
Trump's not gonna do anything you say
anyway oh but what are you saying what
would you say is a strategy for if
you're like hey to win we got to do XYZ
what would you I think I I have I am
terrible on political strategy but one
of the if I if I had been advising Trump
I would have said don't announce in
November five days after a midterm
election I would I would not have done
that if I'm desantis's team I would say
listen you're not even running and in
some polls you're defeating Trump I
would wait continue to allow Trump to be
furious continue to allow Trump to he
had this low energy rally in South
Carolina nobody went he's sweating and
it was bright orange it was just
horrible keep letting Trump do this
stuff where he just looks silly and then
when you finally do announce really
think about it and do it in a way where
you actually launch a formidable
campaign instead of jumping in now and
getting involved in this stuff I
wouldn't do it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]